I'm gonna do this like a boss okay don't
worry I'm almost done getting this
spectacularly wrong y'all set me up hey
y'all it's destiny and today I'm here to
be guessing celebrity ages I feel like
all celebrities are roughly 10 or 20
years older than you think they are I
used to know so much about pop culture
now I feel like I only know the tidbits
I know Beyonce is old enough to be my
sister
that's all I need to know I think I'm
gonna do a solid C because I'm an
average help but I know black don't
crack so here we go all right let's do
this
[Music]
whoa ariana.sea she looked 12 like no
one says it around a grande she acts
like she's 12 1 all right Ariana might
be like I think she's like 20-ish
zendaya cool she is relatively young I
think
which means she's probably 40 someday as
a child she's that why not 30 but not 25
oh hey Lee Bieber younger side I'm
assuming you look great but I think
you're young cause you look like you
model Oh cardi B is 27
I know cardi is 25 because I always
think like what so you're in there
somewhere says there's carly rae jepsen
she was different okay
she looked like Joan Jett this is a call
me life was not fair to you when she
came out on the scene with call me baby
everyone thought she was like 19 and she
was like 30 or something I'm hip I know
pop culture I think she's actually
pretty young well this change about my
whole point yeah okay we don't have to
get back into this cuz you wear this
around the same age Selena Gomez is
older than me something she's like 26 27
yeah you're a baby too much babies Shawn
Mendes is like 12 I know she I know says
this is Kylie Jenner Kylie Jenner who
just lost her best friend
RIPD a friendship you know that really
ages someone but I think she's super
young
there's a big deal because she has all
the money and she's yeah she's younger
than Margot Robbie oh this this young
lady okay you're not quite up there with
her but somewhere in between that so
Margot Robbie I think is in her 40s oh I
think she's right here Margot Robbie's
in her 30s Margot Robbie looks like
she's like just pushing 30 maybe not
quite over the hump it's just he looks
like he's 22 I don't know okay how old
is take off you don't need your credit
take off you don't and I'm sorry for
that but I also know you're like what do
you something
yeah literally what you're here to do is
tell me I'm done nothing with my life
this is Paris Hilton love her I don't
look up my fave white celebrities
because I want to live in ignorance as
Paris Hilton older than cardi B the what
a game Paris I think is in her thirties
like she's one of my car DS like 98%
positive Oh Rachel Weisz I know her
she's familiar I see her she was pretty
dresses and has some nice eye shapes
that's cool
but I know she's older definitely looks
like she hit her 30
oh I'm sorry since if that's not true
I'm really apologize i think rachel is a
good example of like you google her to
see how old she is and it's much older
than you think just because she's so
lovely and youthful I feel like she's
young she's just gone through Thanks
maybe Oh anyway she's the youngest one
Betty why younger than all of us this is
the queen of the England
she always has nice fits and she throw
shade I can see they was like hitting
get miletti I'm not super confident but
I am I'm sticking with this order yeah
Shawn so young I've met Shawn Mendes
once comes off as much older than that
he seems like a like a very grown man
and yeah he's just the child I was I
write that I say 21 not off to a great
start
oh go ahead girl you're just so much
room for your age mature you could've
told me to take off with 40 and I feel
like the other checks out or you could
have said he was 19 that'll be like yeah
that's sure you're still attractive this
like whole group up here I was just like
they're all children find out where
these child go Carney sweet six okay I
don't feel so bad about myself oh well
okay so my top row is actually holding
up really well I'm all over the place
oh I said out loud she was in her
thirties I didn't mean it
see I was I was on to her not the 33 is
old okay like what do they do like like
[Music]
Betty White fellow in the Queen what a
treasure this woman is older than the
Queen and yet still so lively yeah this
wasn't my best day Wow
love being average I feel like I did
okay enough I can still hold my head up
high
well you know just make me feel like
I've done nothing with my life and I
have two degrees anyway please don't
ever leave us like I've worked in a
hospice I've seen people who like all
ages are cheery ating and like she's
very healthy very alert doesn't have to
mention like can't move around like
she's healthy
like she's helped
[Music]